pliability nutrition hydration movement
and mental Fitness these are the five
pillars of the tb12 method by NFL great
Tom Brady he has partnered with wind to
help you be a goat in your own game of
life and Rocky stopped by their new tb12
gym to learn more
the tb12 methods goal is to help you
reach Peak Performance but you cannot do
that without recovery and Coach Rob
corrected me when I got here I thought
that meant stretching but no that's not
what it means right
so yeah like you said stretching's part
of it but we also recommend foam rolling
and self-pliability and stuff like that
and the reason for that is we're trying
to get those muscles nice and long and
pliable right right and the the best
best way to do it is to roll it out so
you think like pizza dough you stretch
pizza dough you sit on a table you walk
away correct it's going back to that
normal shape right go ahead and move
your foot up and down forward okay so
when you roll it out you roll that pizza
dough and you can put your toppings on
you can put in the oven it's going to
stay in that shape
and you're going to be able to eat it
it's going to be delicious right so your
muscles are similar you roll those out
they're going to maintain their shape
longer than if you just stretch your
muscles are like pizza dough you've got
to remember that okay so tell everybody
what you're doing to me right now so
right now what we were just doing we
were working through your muscles again
trying to get that long and pliable
so that you can go out and you can work
out and you're going to you know create
that mind-body connection so that your
your muscles are good to go okay and
when people make their appointment with
you guys you know you would assume you
start on the turf but you actually start
in recovery typically yes we actually
start with recovery because that's one
of the most important things you're
going to do and then we're going to lock
it in with all that strength and
conditioning stuff we're going to do on
the turf all right tell everybody how
they can make an appointment with you or
one of the other body coaches here at
the win at TV 12. so you can go on
tv12sports.com or you can also go
winlasvegas.com you'll be able to find
us on there love it all right coach can
you hit the other cap absolutely okay
thank you